and we're now introducing to stage and
Yuriko and Fredo Silva an is a co
founding partner of floodgate a
primarily early-stage venture fund she's
been called by Forbes one of the most
powerful women in startups she is a
graduate of Yale College the daughter of
a rocket scientist at NASA Palo Alto
native and also a Stanford PhD she's
been working in tech startups since she
was a teenager and prior to floodgate
she worked at Charles River ventures and
McKinsey some of her investments while
at floodgate include lyft I Asti xamarin
refinery29 Chloe and Isabel maker media
TaskRabbit and ModCloth Fredo is the
senior associate at mofos our gracious
host and he graduated from Yale College
with a degree in chemical engineering he
also graduated from Yale Law with a JD
he represents startups VC funds and
strategic investors in early and late
stage investments primarily in life
sciences and food and agricultural
sectors he has also been working as a
metro with EEO entrepreneurship society
advising on social ventures and hybrid
Corp instructors with that I'll let them
take over then I'll try this woman so I
guess the the topic that we have today
Diana's presenting on is hatching
Thunder lizards and when I first saw
that name I was thinking okay hatching
Thunder lizards raising Thunder lizards
finding Thunder lizards it kind of felt
like Pokemon or now this morning I was
thinking more like egg babies which I
started playing so I guess my first
question is what are what are Thunder
lizards yeah so um when it first got
started working at floodgate my
co-founders Mike maples and he's a he's
a former entrepreneur who came from
Austin Texas and he had this term
Thunder lizard which she refers to as
you know what
the top 10 to 20 companies in any given
year and if you look throughout you know
the last 20 years actually billion
dollar-plus
exits not happen in the IT space that
were venture-backed it ranges somewhere
between 10 and 20 plus or minus 5 and so
as a result of that he kept on talking
about what he called thunderlizards in
his very traditional Texan drawl and and
that you know you'd ask him what what is
a thunder lizard and he says well it's
you know an entrepreneur is hatched from
a radioactive atomic egg and there's
something already in their DNA that's
fundamentally different and they swim
across the Pacific Ocean and emerge in
Tokyo Harbor with an attitude and then
you know if you've seen like the classic
Godzilla movies then you have like the
picture of the old-school Godzilla like
emerging with like a little bit of water
and then he comes out and then they're
like shooting laser beams from their
mouths and they're you know chomping on
trains and shoving aside buildings and
that imagery of what Godzilla does as
they disrupt whether in the old school
days is Tokyo now at San Francisco Bay
Area that imagery was actually quite
powerful and when we would describe it
to entrepreneurs they would get it they
would say yeah that's what I am and so
so that's so ever since then we've
always talked about hatching
thunderlizards so to get more specific
then how would one actually go about
doing this how do you how do you grow a
company into a Thunder lizard and what
you know makes you one of those top 20
companies as English from all the other
companies that are out there yeah and I
think this is probably the hardest piece
to answer right so I actually teach a
course on this in the Stanford
engineering school this quarter because
it was a question I continuously got
from students and you would just sort of
do a very simplistic answer and as the
student was walking away I would say
don't really answer that question right
we look at it across the board and
a few different layers I have a
framework which I call the value stack
which I'll also describe but my last
lecture that I gave to the Stanford
students was also particularly impactful
to me because I think it's relevant to a
lot of entrepreneurs today which is that
because of Facebook the movie in Silicon
Valley the show and sort of the
Hollywood ization of Silicon Valley
every entrepreneur who is building a
entrepreneurial venture believes that
they are a high tech startup that is
worthy of venture capital dollars and
the first thing that an entrepreneur
needs to know when they're raising
capital from venture capitalists is that
we are rapacious capitalists and what
that means is that for us for the fund
to work we need to see billion dollar
plus exits and in fact the bigger the
fund the more zeroes you need to attach
to that billion dollar exit when in fact
you know the billion dollar funds that
are being raised today they all need at
least one ten billion dollar plus exit
for that fund to even make sense it's
crazy right and so you hear these great
exits that happen at a hundred one
hundred fifty million dollars where the
entrepreneur did a great job but
fundamentally they're VC's in the back
rooms are saying whatever and that's
tough that's really tough to hear but
most entrepreneurs I don't think
understand that and so from a market
value perspective you have to be able to
justify in the very early days why you
can be a billion dollar ten billion
dollar value company that's very very
hard to do and if you're intellectually
honest about it it's extraordinarily
difficult to do and so you know I see
lots of people come in and they'll pitch
and they'll give us the the Gartner
report that says yeah one trillion
dollars is spent in transportation so
the market size
going after is quite large that's not
really honest right if you actually did
a bottoms-up analysis you actually don't
add up to a trillion dollars unless
you're selling cars selling gas you know
selling all the parts to the cars so
you're selling stuff to yourself like
this is just that it's the the actual
market sizing doesn't make sense so my
first thing that I do is a venture
capitalist is really narrow it down to
is there potential for a billion dollar
plus exit the second thing that we look
at is we have what we call this value
stack and this is these are the the
elements of a business that I'm looking
for and there are four elements to that
business the value stack at the very
bottom is what I call proprietary power
proprietary power is all of the secret
sauce that you have within that business
it's the market insight that you have
that no one else knows it's the
proprietary IP that you have the patents
that you filed it's that supplier that
you've locked in that now no one has
access to it is all of your secret sauce
that you have on day one and is fairly
obvious to the venture capitalist
whether or not it's real so it's very
easy to assess and in looking at that
proprietary power it's stuff that you
can build on over time but generally on
day one you have to have something that
provides defense ability or a moat
around your business the second level is
what I call product power and that's
really more product market fit and if
you've ever read mark and driessen's
original post on product market fit you
should go and read that most people
think product market fit is where a
product fits a market if you read the
original post all he talks about is how
important the market is and that goes
back to market sizing as I was talking
about earlier it's talking also about
the pain that the customer feels and so
therefore the pull of the product by the
market
and so it's not just sort of lobbying a
product into a market and hoping that it
hits it's designing a product so that a
large market that's already apparent to
you with the powerful pain point will
now pull that product in so that's what
we call product market fit and then the
third level is what we call company
power and this is what we work with our
companies on over time within the series
seed or series a company power is all
about building the infrastructure and
the foundational elements of your
business so that you minimize incurring
organizational debt technical debt and
then you ensure you have a scalable
business model and we've seen a lot of
companies in the past get to what we
call traction not a company and you see
this in the headlines of TechCrunch
right zenefits had some huge blow up to
us we were like well that is traction
that has some incredible potential but
you you still need to do a lot of
company development we see that with
business models that aren't fully
functioning that aren't built for scale
or built to last and some of these
companies get to IPO but then they don't
ultimately maintain the legacy and then
the last level of power is what we call
category power and that's probably
actually the most important in order to
have a company that has a long standing
legacy so category is actually about
building your own category to almost
seem like you're entering into a new
market it's your ability to design your
market for yourself so that you aren't
being compared to your competitors and
this is a little bit counter actually to
the whole Lean Startup movement which I
love I love Eric Ries I love Steve Blank
I've taught with him but one of the the
elements that I feel most entrepreneurs
don't get is the art side of
entrepreneurship which is that you have
to provide the due north you have to
provide what the story is you have to
tell the customer what you're creating
because if you constantly ask your
customer your customer can tell you
better
they will never tell you different right
so if you went to a customer who's
shopping at blockbusters and said what's
a better DVD rental system they may not
come up with Netflix because the company
has the founder has to come up with that
vision when I love about the best
founders like Reed Hastings is that they
constantly evolve the category that
they're in I remember hearing a talk
that Reed Hastings gave the early days
in 2000 missive in 2003 in a class he
came to her class me and the student
asked him DVD rentals I mean how long is
that gonna last and he was saying it's
not gonna last forever I totally get it
but I'm building a brand around media
when any family thinks about media
watching a movie tonight they're gonna
think of Netflix it doesn't need to be
DVD rentals through the mail eventually
when streaming happens I'll be the guy
providing them with medium their home so
he was constantly reinventing that
category and so we're looking for
founders who have the capacity and the
imagination and that internal compass to
be able to do the same there's a lot
there talked a lot about special you
know what makes companies special on the
euro VC and I'd actually like to talk a
little bit about what makes VC special
especially because you mentioned that
you helped them out you know in their
stories cito series a and and a lot of
people and I talked about fundraising
they're like yeah I need to find a
strong lead a strong lead a strong lead
and then there's but there's also sort
of the flipside of do you want to take
who's the strong leader you want to take
the cheapest money that's got the best
terms for the company so I guess the
question to you is you know do you see a
lot of value in specific VCS what are
you adding to the table you know do you
want to just take the lowest valuation
or or is there something else there
actually you know a lot of times what I
find is it's not about the valuations
the clean terms right and in fact the
best investors tend to give the cleanest
terms the best investors have found over
time there's no such thing as a good
deal there's only such thing as a great
company and so I've never actually made
money
on fancy terms right and I think most of
the the really good investors in there
some in this room that would actually
you know only provide very very clean
term sheets when it comes to valuation
though you know I would say most of the
really good B C's also are pretty pretty
cheap and so they won't provide you with
a highest valuation that's not how
they're going to compete and that's
because they have the experience of
knowing how important valuation is but
I've never seen actually great VC's give
totally unfair evaluations there are
there's a reasoning behind their
valuations that's what I would say first
the second is in terms of picking a
venture capitalist to work with you
should just do your homework right that
every every venture capitalist if
they're gonna work with someone they're
doing back-channel referencing and I'm
always shocked with how little
back-channel referencing people do on
our firm or the people within our
companies and we're always actually
proactively providing them with lists of
people to go and talk to but I'm shocked
at some of these firms which actually
have a very very known reputation within
the entrepreneurial community for
certain kinds of behavior and they don't
get called out on those things and so I
would just say you know you need to ask
people and then the last piece is you
know there are things that each partner
is actually an expert on so you want to
make sure you're getting the person from
whom you want that certain kind of help
right and so as an example my partner
Mike is one of the best marketers I have
ever met in my entire life he can create
categories like no one I've ever met
he's great at creating incredible
differentiated narratives but if you
asked him you know tell me about the
metrics for you know great companies in
this category he would be like I'll tell
you a great story and you know let me
tell you about how
you should position it he's not that
kind of investor and so in those cases
I'm more that so I'll come in and I'll
help out so you need to know also first
of all how which partner has what
strengths but then secondly within a
partnership how do they operate right
some partnerships are you get that one
partner and no one else is really going
to come to their aid and in other
partnerships everyone's sort of
incentivized to share the load and so
you should ask about that and you should
ask if you can get access to the other
partners if you think that some of the
other partners can also help so you
mentioned that you know you're looking
at the the top 20 companies that are
going to be the best companies make a
billion dollars you know there's there
was an article a couple days ago about
their nose well on that but one of the
points of the article was that a red
flag was that there were none of the key
the top 20 VCS in there there's this
sort of like idea that it perpetuates
that there's like 20 top tech theses in
2012 life sciences VCS and the rest of
it yeah you know do you feel that's true
or have people in the VC space you've
talked to like talked about it or have
any feelings about that with fairness or
or like the idea that you know if you're
a company you don't have one of these
top B C's behind you it's sort of like
why bother I don't necessarily agree
with that I'm just wondering what you
feel like I don't necessarily agree with
that but but having said that I do think
VC is a business of exceptionalism so if
you look at the world of VC and you
actually look into the limited partners
data of which I've been privy to some
they will tell you that there is only a
small handful of venture capital firms
that are really worth investing in there
are only a small handful that really
make money so in the exact same way
entrepreneurship is this incredible
power law distribution the venture
capitalists are also exactly on that
power law distribution and the reason is
the best VCS get access
to the winning lottery tickets much more
often than the other VCS do and so I
think the the reputation of the VC firms
amongst other VC firms and amongst their
entrepreneurs is actually quite
important and this notion of the top 20
VCS I think is an important one to keep
in mind I think though that there's also
ways in which you can cut it by sector
as well so in life science it's not
going to be the same as if you look in
an IT and there are some specialized
ones like emergence capital or ribbit
which have specific areas in which they
are really well known and so again there
they would be in in some some really
good company if you can get those people
especially if you're in within those
sectors so how did you get to become a
VC what was your your career path that
got you there so my career path is
extraordinarily winding I'll take you
guys like really way back so I when I
started at at Yale way back in the day I
wanted to be a doctor
and before that actually it was my dad
my parents were all engineers and so
they're all Mechanical Engineers and my
big rebellion was I was an electrical
engineer I ended up and I thought I was
gonna be either a doctor research
scientists and then when I was gonna be
a doctor I just was having dinner with
my roommate from Yale last night we were
laughing because she is a doctor and we
actually had one summer we're studying
for the MCATs and I remember like riding
my bike up science hill towards Kaplan
must have been somewhere up there and it
was two days before the MCATs and I
turned to my roommate said Kathy I just
had a revelation she's like what is it
we just need to get there before
everyone grabs the exams and I'm like I
hate hospitals
I don't like sick people I don't have as
much empathy as you do
she's talking my I'm like I don't think
I should be a doctor and so like two
days before the MCATs I decided like I
shouldn't be a doctor
and so I went through with the MCATs but
then I this existential crisis and that
year actually uh I was working as
work-study for the Dean of engineering
and just doing you know filing for saris
Kubus who was this administrative
assistant and I I worked really hard to
like give her perfect photocopies and
like do some some cool things for her in
Excel and she just really she just
really cared for me and like would give
me extra money to go buy like a Dunkin
Donuts delivery I really remember this
fondly anyway one day she she had spoken
well of me to the Dean of engineering
and so he pops his head out and he says
was Dean out and DL and Bromley if any
of you know him and he says who are you
and I said oh I'm Anne he said I have a
guest here could you give him a tour and
I said sure so I gave him a tour this
guy there was a guest for the Dean a
tour of the Yale campus and this guy
starts peppering me with questions where
are you from like what do you do what do
you like to do and I'm announcer around
these questions and I get to I'm from
Palo Alto and he's like oh I'm from Palo
Alto this is what are you doing for
Spring Break I said well I'm going back
home he's like that's great how would
you like to come visit me see what I do
for a living and I said that'd be great
like what do you do and he said I'm the
CEO of hewlett-packard I literally
shadowed Luke Platt around for a week
this is like classic Yale experience
that means everyone has this that's why
I tell all of the admits and the people
I interview for you and and it was a
life-changing experience as you can
imagine but when I got back he had sent
me two pictures one was I'm sitting this
couch talking to
and there's a photographer around
because there was a big event with
Microsoft happening the second picture
was Bill Gates sitting exactly in that
same seat talking to Lou and I have this
framed in my office to this day because
I still get emotional just thinking
about it there's this there's this huge
you know fortune 50 company guy sending
me two pictures that's basically saying
dream big you know you can be Bill Gates
or at least sit in the same seat ascend
to a to a girl who's just like a junior
at Yale trying to figure out life that
was a big thing and and I ended up
wanting becoming really interested in
business and I ended up working at
McKinsey for a few years and really
loved that experience but a friend of
mine at Yale was this guy he was really
into financial services and only a way
like a Yalie can be is like he knew
everything about financial services and
he looked at me one day as a Ewing you
should go into venture capital you're
good at technology you're interested in
business and for my birthday he had this
like directory a venture capitalist
photocopied for me I was like I don't
even know what to do with this but it
connected me then with my friend's dad
who who was a venture capitalist who
gave me some an early advice basically
which was go get some operational
experience it's cute that you're an
interest in venture capital but now it's
not the time but it opened up some doors
for me to talk to other venture
capitalists and one day I met this guy
Ted inter Smith who was a partner
Charles River ventures and he invited me
to come talk to him and I think they had
an analyst position but I didn't really
think I was going to get it there were
like 10 people out the door who were
interviewing for the same position and
but we sat down and we we started
talking and this is like where the Yale
education really comes into play so he
asked me what books are you reading
and at the time I was really into some
modern American literature and I was
telling him bowel the fiction books I
was reading I just talking his head off
about this one novel I was reading at
the time and he happened to really be
into literature so he was an English Lit
major so we talked about that for a
while and then he said well what music
do you listen to it uh oh you know again
I was like a classical pianist at yeah I
love classical piano music there's you
know been to Carnegie Hall and this is
what I'm really into at the hormone this
is a recording you should really listen
to it turns out he's really into opera
we spent an hour and a half talking not
about technology at all just about books
we love to read history you know people
that we thought were really interesting
political events and then at the end of
that conversation I'm like am i
interviewing for a position he says this
is great I think we I think we'd make a
great combination you should come work
for me I that was the strangest
interview I've ever had and then without
even asking what the compensation was
gonna be I said that would be a great
idea I was living in the Bay Area at the
time I had to move all the way across to
Boston but fortunately some my really
good friends were living there and ended
up there my second day of work was 9/11
and then so I witnessed really a
slowdown in the venture economies or
what happens in that case I was thinking
of applying the law school I applied to
law school my husband was in law school
I decided that was the wrong choice for
me and then rethought everything and
ended up at a ph.d program in operations
research applied math at Stanford
plopped down there and that's where the
story gets even stranger I was asked to
then ta a bunch of engineering school
classes on my entrepreneurship I thought
I was going to start a company and so
use the opportunity to start developing
a product in what now is probably
behavioral modeling in computer security
then as I developed something I turned
to my advisor and said I think we have
something I'd love to see if we can make
a company out of it
and my old mentor at Charles River
ventures said you should go talk to some
angels you've been in this ph.d program
for a few years you don't know what the
real world is like and so I went and
found an angel so this is Mike maples
I'd met him in a class he was a mentor
to a group of students that was working
in the class and this is we have been
most incredible mentors we had Diane
Greene was a mentor in this class we had
the former CEO of Symantec we just had
these crazy people and one team was
really underperforming and they were
just fighting with each other constantly
fighting and I looked up the the who the
mentor was and it was Mike maples and so
I emailed him and I said hey you're not
doing your job I know you're a volunteer
but here's his team they're high
potential they're bickering they're
about to fail the class you need to do
something about it he said oh I'm gonna
take care of it they're gonna get an A+
and he did actually manage to get this
team an A+ and so afterwards we were we
grabbed some time together and and he
invited me to come and look at the deals
that he was looking at at the time we
called them unpartitioned to it he
called me and he said I have this great
idea I just completely accidentally
raised a fund it's thirty five million
dollars and I think you should drop out
of the ph.d program and join me as a
co-founder and it's not a venture back
startup like you're thinking about but
it's a back to venture startup he's
really good with words so I was like
this guy's crazy like there's I mean I'm
you imagine Who I am at that moment
first of all I had like a 18 month old
daughter I was in PhD candidate but
don't have the degree not a proven
investor at all so I didn't really
understand why he would want me as a
co-founder
but really enjoyed working with him
really enjoyed it
really thought I could learn a lot and
then in the midst of it knew that this
is 2008 financial crisis is happening
that this was the time to actually start
a company in that area my mom did not
believe me and she thought I was insane
but the more she thought I was insane
the more other people tried to talk me
out of it the more I knew this is what I
wanted to do and so in 2008 they so it's
a six years now where or no sorry
this is 2008 so it's been eight years we
we've been working together cool so even
first for venture capital firms finding
your co-founder and your partner is
pretty important it's it's vitally
important for startups you know you have
an engineering degree so do I I also
have a law degree
you also you know no numbers and math
and money and you get a lot of people at
Yale that are also very well rounded and
it turns out or a mechanical engineer
and art major and but still a lot of us
don't necessarily have all the skill
sets that we need and need to find a
co-founder especially in the tech field
to to actually make things work and
finding the wrong co-founder can just
make things the opposite of work so what
advice do you have for people looking
for a co-founder and to get their
Thunder lizard hatched yeah I think you
know I was just talking to Mike Krieger
about his process for for starting to
work with Kevin Systrom and I thought it
was really interesting what they did
they actually would work in coffee shops
on like a prototype startup so before
they decided to work on the actual thing
bourbon at the time they would get
together every Saturday and for I think
five or six hours prototype something
and and it allowed them to figure out
how they would disagree what what their
personalities were like what happened
when they disagreed how do they feel
talking to each other
and I thought that was really
interesting because that's sort of what
I did with my cry like we prototyped are
a relationship by getting together every
Wednesday and you know when I would
disagree with him I would just sort of
tell him and we could figure out if that
was gonna be a bad thing or a good thing
and and I feel like not enough
entrepreneurs do that they don't really
figure out if that relationship will
work when things go badly they they
assume that everything will always go
well I also did a lot of back-channel
referencing so I did talk to a lot of
people who had worked with Mike to make
sure that he was someone I wanted to
work with in our last test was that we
took all of our our families out for a
joint dinner so he could see how I deal
with my kids which is not pretty he
could see how you know I interact with
my husband I could see how he interacts
with his family and and you know even
actually when we were still prototyping
and we were just working together
casually we weren't signed on to work
together we actually even did a trip out
to Austin where we are meeting with a
lot of his former business colleagues so
I could actually ask them questions we
even stayed with his parents I got to
stay in the granddaughters room and so
like you get to you have to get to
really know people before you start
working together and I don't think
enough people do that when they do it
can actually be quite magical like my
Krieger and Kevin Systrom you know
continue to work together in Instagram
even way after that's been acquired and
I think that's the kind of winning
relationship you seek to have so one of
the one of the factors that you
mentioned sort of him started about
about what makes some company a Thunder
lizard is basically finding the right
opportunity in the market and that's
actually something that we talked about
earlier today when Donna was thinking
about you know what's the future so I
guess the question for you
you know what areas you think are right
for disruption what's the what's the
future yeah this is um
I've been looking a lot at big data so
my my my PhD was in math modeling of
computer security and involved a lot of
data and as a result of some of the the
things that I learned during that that
research when I encountered this one
company called EOS T it was out of
Stanford's math department I discovered
that there were things that they were
talking about within their research that
really resonated for me
and that was my very first investment in
in big data and since then I haven't
really made many investments I've
studied the field quite a bit but I
didn't really know what I believed and
so over the last 12 months myself as
well as one of the new partners it's
working with us
we've been working on what do we really
believe and I think I'm coming out of
sort of the confusion that I had which
was for a long time I believe that the
big businesses were going to be these
horizontal platforms and a yosity is one
of them they can take extraordinarily
complex data in almost any field and
tell you something very interesting
about it and so there's lots of why
different kinds of applications whether
it's in health care or insurance into
financial services in government and
people Pollin tier would say that their
technology is a lot like that as well
there's also infrastructure companies in
that space whether it's in data at rest
and data lakes or data in motion with
transactional data and those are all
areas that where we're looking at
broadly but I don't have a really real
good thesis there the place where I've
become increasingly interested is that
in the same way you know in all these
marketplaces when you're like in
marketplaces they're a great horizontal
plays but then the ones that really took
off were highly horizontal silly lifts
was a really interesting example to me
because a TaskRabbit which I was also
invested in we actually had drivers
driving people around but it was not
nearly as big as when you had a market
place solely devoted for it to that and
I think that actually in the big data
space
we're gonna start to see enterprise
applications that are fully focused in
specific areas and it won't look like a
big data application it'll look like a
normal enterprise application it'll look
like workday just smarter right and the
reason why I believe that is that for
these big data companies to work you
actually have to own the data
to some extent you have to own the data
you have to know how its cleaned you
know how you need to know how to process
it you need to know where it's where it
resides and who has access to it and
only then can you actually start to then
create really interesting models that
then can be updated on the fly and be
really smart so the canonical example to
me is that people pay millions of
dollars for Oracle financials and yet
this is very much a static you input
numbers in it spits out numbers that are
fairly known it's a data logging
enterprise software but if I'm gonna pay
millions of dollars for something like
that I would expect it to almost replace
my fpn a guy right and at least allow
them to just use their intuition to
adjust the models but right now we still
have to create the budget and put it
into Oracle financials it doesn't just
self generate and continue to become
better over time
I think enterprise software will become
more like self-driving applications I
was I have a Tesla and it was like the
one of the most mind-blowing experience
is going down to 80 you just press this
little lever twice and it goes blue and
next thing you know you let go of the
steering wheel and it's like it's
navigating to 80 for you and it's the
craziest thing and I was showing my
husband like look it's no hands don't do
that
that's a magical it's like what we call
this WTF moment where you're like dad I
never thought that was possible we don't
have that as often in enterprise
software enterprise software is like you
have a nice pretty UI with around
buttons and pretty colors and everyone's
like oh right but if you can actually
make it smarter and allow you to have
the people with great intuition use
their intuition and focus on their
intuition lead led work rather than the
mind-numbing elements of the work that
they don't enjoy then I think we would
have a much more productive work force
and so I'm really looking forward to the
enterprise applications that become more
self-driving that leverage Big Data we
started out the conversation talking
about what makes the Thunder lizard
succeed and startup succeed I guess
you've seen a whole bunch of them either
pitched or ones that you've worked on
the boards of and invested in and so I'd
ask you what are the biggest mistakes
that you see I'm not going to ask you
about that what are the biggest mistakes
do we see um I think it is actually you
know it was talking about the value
stack so proprietary our product product
power company power category power I
think the biggest myths is that we see
are actually in the foundational
elements of company power and category
power so either the company doesn't
invest the time and really a defining
culture or their values implementing
that figuring out you know how to work
an organization so that their best
people stay making sure that they don't
incur unneeded technical debt all of
those things actually make the company
lose time makes them lose time it makes
them lose inertia and this business is
all about forward momentum and and then
the last area around category power
that's actually how you create value
that wasn't even there and to me you
know we we spend so much time saying
it's all about the product it's it's the
product will sell itself
and I know in the best company
it's just not true it's there's a story
that customers buy into and it's it's
when your customers become irrational
about your product that real value can
be extracted and I think that there's an
urgency around that there's a great book
that's coming out called play bigger
that's gonna be available in June that
talks precisely about this and they
they've discovered that each category
has a six to ten year lifespan and if
you go much beyond that the the public
as well as just sort of investors get
tired of that sector and that's why
there's so much urgency for for
companies to actually not just go and
execute but out execute and be able to
get out and be liquid within a certain
time frame and so I think it's around
that the urgency and then the
foundational elements of the business
that that I'd like to see all right good
question the bath all right second stand
up George yep
hi thank you for taking my question in
so I was kind of curious to hear your
take on education technology
entrepreneurship I was reading an
article recently that says that over the
last twenty five years ten billion
dollars of venture capital has gone into
education technology to produce exactly
one unicorn to you right so none of
those ten billion dollar mega unicorns
happening just one one billion dollar
startup does this mean that there's no
hope for education technology especially
K through 12 and yeah I feel like I
could ask a lot of questions about this
but specifically what do you think as an
education technology entrepreneur what
are your options and how does your firm
specifically feel when approached by an
entrepreneur looking to do something
education oriented yeah we've actually
made a few investments in education so
check I would say was probably one of
the first ones for us and they become an
acquirer for a lot of these these tech
company
is that that have a sort of a smaller
sliver what I found is actually it's
very difficult to make money with in
education and yet there are massive
opportunities still we invested in a
company called clever which is a
platform that's being sold into into
school districts and they've they
actually have quite quite good
penetration because then different
application developers can also then
access these schools without having to
go school district by school district I
believe that the other place where
things are changing is in the college
market and I think things will have to
change there just because the cost is
not it's not justified by the value
people are getting out of it and and so
fundamentally education will change over
the next 10 to 15 years
I just don't think anyone's figured out
the business model that unlocks it
I just even look at the education my
kids are getting you know we live in
Menlo Park it's a great school district
and yet you look at the assignments that
these kids have and like they're talking
about there's a picture of a phone and
it doesn't even look like it's like a
the kind of phone I saw in my household
with like the little thing that would
rotate around my son's like what is that
I'm like
it's a phone you know and so the content
is fundamentally dated and so and the
kids they're just changing and adapting
so quickly that being given information
that's even five years old just feel so
disconnected to them and I just I
believe that there's a better way but
the key to that is gonna have to be
you're gonna have to unlock the value
and the question is then who holds the
wallet they're related to that are
thunder unicorns are related to our
Thunder lizards related to unicorns
that's kind of the same mystical magical
animal well so this is funny his what
when aliens report came out I turned to
Mike was like hey what do you think
about that and he was like unicorns
aren't even real animals in a Mike we
share an office I turned around and I
was like staring at him for a second
he's she's dead serious right I hit like
this I still can't believe he said that
Thunder lizards are our actual exits and
I think that that's the important
difference because that does make them
fundamentally more rare and it's not
susceptible to the whims of a select
group of people who decide that the
value is over a billion dollars
no we don't actually we're so far
removed from the exit environment that
our strategy doesn't change and as I was
mentioning the actual number of exits
that are greater than a billion dollars
has still maintained consistency over
the last even five years and so even
though people are delaying there are
still companies that are getting out at
greater than a billion dollars I think
Emma neighs have actually also gone down
quite a bit
but we've still seen you know pretty
consistently ten to twenty I think that
the big question has been the ones that
everyone's watching those tend not to go
out we have a question from Dora who is
a psychiatrist who has a mental health
startup who flew here from New Mexico
directly said that
yeah I think so in healthcare in general
I think is also becoming very
interesting so even for my AI a big data
space we're actually seeing a lot of
really interesting companies not only in
healthcare Arabic sending out into life
science so I think they're we're gonna
continue to see a lot of innovation
mental health I've actually seen a few
companies pop up on our radar screen a
lot of that is has to do with access to
mental health care I think that you know
there's still a lot of innovation left
to be done one of the companies I'm
working with is actually company called
in skopic switch is literally a
microscope that you could attach to a
mouse's brain and you can see the actual
circuitry working and so used to be you
could really see a couple of neurons but
in this case you can see hundreds maybe
even thousands of neurons and when a
mouse goes through an actual maze you
could say you can actually find out that
there are certain neurons that fire in
certain locations so your brain
literally has a map and what we found
there is that because the brain is
literally a circuit the hope is that in
the same way we've had genetics really
start to move the needle and personal
medicine the belief is that the if the
brain is a circuit we shouldn't just be
treating it with chemicals right it
really needs to be treated on a
circuitry basis but we have no
understanding what that looks like and
so in scope X is one of the first
companies to really start to develop
tool sets to understand what the
circuitry looks like and my belief is if
we can do that you'll have a basis for
actual treatment and in fact the White
House is super excited about the
technology that they've done and all
these Nobel laureates are using it and
our belief is that you know within the
next ten years will actually have
therapeutics coming out based on the
knowledge that we're gaining through
this type of device so you know from a
tech
cool area I think we're gonna start to
see a lot of movement in just
understanding the brain thank you folks
who've been tweeting and rocking it all
day with the Elle tech 16 genu Jessica
where yell entertainer Institute keep it
coming question in the front I am BOTS
are the new apps or so is the mantra
being repeated on the streets of San
Francisco right now and as somebody that
is currently working on a very early
stage bot startup I'm wondering if
you're starting to see any entrepreneurs
pitching you on BOTS and what business
models you're optimistic or believe
optimistic that or believe have merit I
think it's a very early stage in the
hype cycle that we're rapidly ascending
it and just talking to some of the
developers out there and friends that
are working on in the space it's just
very interesting and as I go through my
process of trying to figure out how I
want to monetize this would be curious
to hear your thoughts on on the space
yeah I it's been we've actually been
seeing businesses we're always were
either early or way too early or it's
almost illegal we we've seen bot
companies probably for about a year now
and so we've we've placed a few
investments the question I have is
whether or not they're actually apps or
just a front-end for existing apps and
and so you know the the notion that
Facebook wants to become serve an app
store is an interesting one and I think
it's something that we should all track
but it's also closed ecosystem right
because it is based on whatsapp it's
based on Facebook Messenger and the
truth is in the u.s. we use a ton of
different messaging platforms in Asia
you see you know everyone from my my
grandmother to my cousin is using line
and that makes it a platform everyone is
on it but we don't have the equivalent
here in the US and so it's still a
fairly messy ecosystem and I don't think
people fully have dropped
I think we're just hoping that Facebook
is enough of a platform that we can we
can go in and access lots of customers
that way but the younger crew is not
they're their own snapshot and so I
think we're still going to continue to
see a fragmented space and how that gets
solved is interesting to me and there
are companies that are trying to do that
I also think that having all these
developers who are already developing
for iOS and Android and for different
environments than to ask them to develop
for messenger and whatsapp and you know
snapchat and where all of these actually
have very different characteristics in
terms it's much more different than
Android versus iOS so how do you even
have a develop or do that I think that's
gonna be really challenging so it's not
one of these things that's gonna take
off overnight I remember I ordered
something from Zulily and Zulily texted
me everything over facebook Messenger
and it was fine but it was no different
from email and so unless you do
something fundamentally different from
email over that messaging platform I
think that there's still a lot of work
to be done I have a question for the
audience who here is in tech already
here wants to get into tech and not I am
in the tech who is a start-up CEO or
founder okay cool investors species
developers designers PR marketing social
media all right cool just fine I get it
it's the best if you're paying attention
you can figure out who you need to go
make a company after the next break okay
so my question over here okay so yes
care there is Rehan hi there my name is
Peter Matthews I'm founder CEO of Modi
and a designer I had an engineer but I
wanted to ask more about you say early
stage like ridiculously early stage and
we've seen over the past few years is
the shift in the bar raising for seed
funds so we're you know full disclosure
of fundraising for my company and trying
to navigate Oh are we see a tree Angela
read this new
could you tell a little bit about what
you look for in floodgate the other
thing is that we are a hardware company
so are there differences between the
expectations between software and
hardware when it comes to that bar
yeah that's those are very good
questions um so I think a few things
that you need to know when you're
approaching venture capital firm is
roughly what they're chuck size is like
how often they make investments whether
they lead or not and and it you know and
part of that leads into what stage they
invest in though the part of the reason
why I'm at I would ask how often they
invest is some companies will invest
especially at the early stage in a lot
of different companies and other firms
like ourselves we only vast you know I
as a partner will invest in three
companies in the entire year and so even
though I'm early-stage I'm not writing a
check every week and so it's early-stage
relative to and I I'm early-stage
meaning I'm usually the first
institutional dollars in but I can wait
to find that company that has some
outsized metrics relative to not having
raised any capital at all so I think a
lot of people will come to us and
they're surprised and say well we
thought you were early stage but what
the founder forgot was that it's not
just your characteristics is your
characteristics relative to all the
other companies that are pitching us in
that entire quarter because I'm only
going to pick one in that entire quarter
and so you know just to give you a sense
we see I get a hundred two hundred fifty
emails a week I get I meet with five to
ten companies in a week and I only
invest in three companies per year so
that just gives you a sense of what my
funnel looks like right and and in terms
of metrics the the hard truth is it
totally depends on what kind of company
you are but one of the things that I
encourage a lot of entrepreneurs to
think about
especially if you're on a revenue run
rate which is 99% of you unless you're
snapchat or Instagram or one of these
companies that are high flyers that are
sure to get a lot of eyeballs then and
in that case you have to be tracking
towards 10 million monthly active users
in year one and only then can you say
you're an eyeballs driven business if
you're a revenue based business what
we're starting to see is about at the
end of year one which could actually be
when you're raising your first seed
round we're seeing about a hundred
thousand dollars a month in revenues by
year two it's five hundred thousand and
that's like plus or minus two hundred
thousand dollars a month in revenues by
year five it's two to three dot a
million dollars a month in revenues now
that's gonna be different for hardware
because you have that hardware
development phase and so they're what we
would be actually looking at is what is
your technical IP what's your
proprietary IP that you have that we
would believe is defensible and then how
quickly can you develop it on it so if
you're if you're still developing
prototypes in year two year three it's
gonna be very very difficult and so
we're looking at timeline as well as how
proprietary your IP is that's an awesome
answer Carol I know you were typing away
on that go ahead and tweet that as well
cuz eyes are great notes and ranges I
want to make sure everyone shares that
very cool we have time for one more
question
before our break yes Robert you're Santa
there's more overlap these days of
social enterprises being compatible with
both impact investment and venture
capital investment in the context of the
fears that some social enterprises have
that if they took investment from the
wrong investors they their business
model gets distorted or it gets work
during gets shifted in some way they
don't want well what do you think is the
role of the venture industry of easily
the social enterprises or the high
impact potential startups in terms of
them achieving those their values and
y'all's values collectively
I think it depends on how you define
social impact you know there's a friend
of mine has a VC firm called uprising
where where he is looking actually at
the social impact as well and he
invested in lyft and he you know and the
way I think about it is an in floodgate
really thinks about this too we we talk
about funding movements not just
companies and in that I think that you
know as we were talking about categories
really the narrative becomes incredibly
important and you know when I funded
lift it was still called Zimride and all
they talked about was transportation 2.0
and this is before over two years before
uber this was the only cop we had was
Zipcar there are no other transportation
startups in the space but they were
telling this incredible story of how
they wanted to increase efficiency of
road usage they wanted more than one
person in every car and they talked
about how people sharing the ride really
made a difference in people's lives and
you see that narrative actually in the
product that they continue to deliver
they talk about you know how do you
enable car pools they have this new car
pool product where does that come from
that car pool product came from their
exact original vision and so I'm really
taken by companies that have a strong
narrative that have that movement
component to it and if you call that
social enterprise I would be funding
those all day long I think there is a
difference though between there's social
enterprise where profit ultimately is
not the motive I think you know we are
venture capitalists which means we're a
capitalist so we need to see returns and
we are therefore you know we're
representing our limited partners but I
do believe that actually attracting
talent is one of the hardest things to
do today and the easiest way to do that
is by having a really compelling story
to tell as to why your company exists
and so in that sense I think you know a
social enterprise as a movement I think
is really a great
way to think about businesses being
built and social investments and impact
investments you know I agree that most
VCS you know the bottom line is is
making money at the end and even for
social enterprise that's different than
being a non-profit and that you actually
are also trying to make money but
there's a slight other focus of there
and I think probably you know the Yelp
community is one of the best communities
to get that from because so many people
that are Yale graduates and have money
are also civic minded and so a lot of
what you'll see is like family offices
or institutions that are like quasi
nonprofit like RSS social finance or
MIDI are you know there there are the
kinds of firms I can really do that and
even if you do happen upon a VC that
will be willing to put in there and
there are that will do that you know
there's a lot of things you can do with
your corporate forum to protect to
protect the the mission and keep the
mission on line you know everybody knows
about protective provisions in your
charter you know voting rights and
things like that you can do the same
thing for mission alignment
thanks for the the funnel that you
talked about with the you know three
investments per year but a hundred fifty
emails per day per week 100 field that's
still a lot of the hundred fifty per
week how do you determine which one to
open and is met you at the Yelp tech
event one of them anyway you have to
answer that it's good it's getting
awesome so thank you and and thank you
Fredo for a great conversation super
enlightening on the VC special bit of
applause